follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the Lange focused Channel and my name is
Paul
today's video is mystery languages or
and you guess the mystery languages for
each language
I'll give you an audio sample to listen
to and after that I'll give you a
written sample of the language that you
can see what it looks like
and then I'll give you a moment to make
a note of your answer to make a note of
your guest before I reveal the answer to
you so let's begin with the first
language that one was actually a giraffe
giraffes normally communicate through
infrasonic sounds that humans can't hear
so you probably won't hear a giraffe
making sounds like that any time soon so
I guess we'll just move on to a human
language
please listen opposition leader Don
Polaris Anna Ponte was still on country
long fashion approaches see some
high-level animals full emitter for PSS
policy in Ocala FL akaike Vilonia and
making the flat tops off anyone
telepaths around East Oakland Gaussian
state if the headmaster with almost
Coulomb south in region now some written
examples book belong who's that Emma got
plenty money me no come because me sick
so what language is it
[Music]
the language is cock-teasing Shakti
Singh is an english-based Creole that is
spoken in Papua New Guinea you may have
noticed some English words or some words
that sounded strangely similar to
English but pronounced differently
that's because most of talk patience
vocabulary came from English while the
basis of its grammar came from local
languages let's take a look at some of
those sentences again book belong who
that means whose book or whose book is
this book means book belong comes from
the long but is used to show possession
in tox PC who that means who and I think
it comes from English who's that so word
forwarded book belong who and they got
plenty money means he has much money em
means he it comes from him actually he
is a word that comes before a predicate
that means has and it comes from English
God plumpie means much or plenty and
moniece means money of course we know
come because me see means I didn't come
because I'm sick the verb tense is not
really specified but it would be clear
from the context me means I and it comes
from the English me because in talk
listen there's no distinction between
the subject and the object pronoun no
shows a negative come means come because
means because then there's me again and
fix min-sik so you can see that speaking
top-15 is sort of like speaking English
with a kind of simplified grammar and
some different pronunciation but of
course there's more to it than that
okay on to the next language our usual
into absolutely missing image sexual was
aa food among our be one more show every
window funda mind about Miss Pooja
so without any longer example your
packet divorce inside which is we are
fact if you more than food job out to
watch it now let's see some written
samples table watching Luca P Camilla
logo given no Kakuma gangland so what
language do you think it is
the language is Zulu Zulu is a member of
the Bantu language family and is spoken
by around 10 million people mainly in
South Africa but also when nearby
Botswana Lesotho Malawi Mozambique and
Swaziland one feature you may have
noticed while listening was some click
sound listen to this phrase again ok no
cool Megan I notice that the letter C
stands for a click sound here you can
Oakley Megan LAN and here's a short clip
from that audio sample again this time
listen for the click among our bit more
motion funda mind the bug movie future
so browsing any longer showing them who
decided clicks our linguistic feature
sounds almost exclusively in African
languages specifically in the been
through and critic language families
okay on to the next language allow me to
attach anything Ragusa mulatto graphics
image module a nice Cova da Jia Xin
tsunami Civitas Tapia Dennis peg of
Chechnya
Raju receipt issue go with Jenna me
Audrey Gaston Shindo kaneto no ill mo
Guevara cockpit stage Roger mr. ting
little chorus Jionni I'm attached oh
Allah tag substituted saturation Donna
to Escobar the chance Tony Usha sprouts
don't and now let's see the language
reaction Montoya Regina
Tapani movie Palmdale school proshanto
to reach to Estrella
so what's the mystery language if Polish
polish is a member of the Slovak
language family so if you guessed a
different Slovak language like Russian
then you were pretty close polish has
around 55 million native speakers mainly
in Poland but it's also spoken by Polish
minorities in other countries here are
some hints that this language is polish
there are numerous diacritic marks
including the Cresta which looks like an
acute accent and the ogonek like a
little tail attached to these vowels
there are also digraphs and trigraphs
that represent single consonant sounds
like these ones so you'll see these
combinations of letters quite frequently
in Polish you'll also see the letter Y
used as a vowel so it often appears
between continents or after a consonant
the end of a word if you'd like to learn
more about the Slovak language family
check out my video on the subject right
here I hope you had fun guessing today's
mystery languages be sure to go down to
the comment section and tell us what you
guessed and tell us why you guess that
way as always that will probably start
some interesting discussions be sure to
check out the various length okis social
media accounts like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and lately some subscribers
have been telling me that they haven't
been getting notifications about my new
videos if you've had that problem or if
you want to be sure that you always know
when new videos are released
then go to my channel page and click on
this bell icon right here and turn on
notifications so that you'll never have
that problem again once again I'd like
to say thanks to all of my patreon
supporters especially these fantastic
people right here on the screen if you
don't know what patreon is then check
out my patreon page at patreon.com slash
lang focus and become a supporter if you
feel like doing so thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]